wealth surprise surprise there were
almost no mentions of the immigrant
caravan of the day after the 2018
midterms on right-wing media or the day
after the day after the 2018 midterms on
right-wing media and as if we didn't
realize that it was a political football
from day one remember the Pentagon told
the Trump administration the caravan is
no threat the military told the
commander's being sent down to the
border that they need to be aware of the
armed militias that are going to be down
there to protect the border from the
immigrant caravan and that they are
really the threat of chaos but even
though we knew all this was a ploy for
attention in advance of the midterms it
didn't matter because it worked they did
it and now that the midterms are over
even Fox and Friends in their show after
election election day they have been
constantly fear-mongering about the
caravan they barely mentioned it it
reminds me of Ebola before the 2014
midterms I don't know if you remember
but the write was harping on obama and
the Dems are horrible they're not
handling Ebola correctly they're
allowing this to become an epidemic that
was will spread endlessly they don't
know what to do the midterms go by and
Ebola is barely ever mentioned again
well in the last few weeks Fox News has
been sort of a primary source of this
erratic unhinged fear-mongering around
this immigrant caravan that's heading to
the border they talked about the the
caravan even as we were learning about a
right-wing anti-semite killing 11 people
in a Pittsburgh synagogue late last
month and to focus in a little bit on
Fox and Friends this has been a top
program for Trump himself as well he
loves watching it he sometimes calls in
to Fox & Friends on Friday Fox and
Friends talked about the caravan 19
times Monday 10 times the caravan was
discussed Tuesday on election day when
they could have just been talking about
voting nine times
they even had a reporter embedded with
the caravan for live updates about its
progress and Wednesday the day after the
election one mention in passing barely a
blip in fact that Henry said something
like many in the media laughed when the
president framed the midterms as about
Cavanaugh and the caravan that mention a
total sidebar was the one time that the
caravan was mentioned yesterday barely a
blip today if the caravan were an
invasion if the caravan were a threat to
our national security
if the caravan warrants coverage even as
we're learning about an anti-semitic
gunman killing 11 people in a synagogue
in Pittsburgh Pennsylvania
wouldn't that all still be important to
talk about after the election wouldn't
it still be newsworthy after the
election if we are about to be invaded
by a group of mostly Latino but also
Middle Easterners who have snuck into
the group and are pretending to be
Latino wouldn't that still be important
and to be clear I'm not complaining the
Caravan keeps dwindling in size it's
somewhere around 17 or 18 hundred miles
from the us-mexico border I'm not
complaining that the coverage is
dwindling what I'm pointing out is the
completely brazen political nature of
this garbage and that's what's
disgusting that's what's completely
transparent it's almost like there
wasn't really a threat and it was a very
cheaply put together ploy to scare
people and to take attention away from
serious criticisms of the Republican
agenda that we're seeing am I wrong here
Pat in pointing this out or or is is
there some other explanation no I do
think you're right and unfortunately it
looks like the fear-mongering worked
because if you take a look at the border
states Ted Cruz defeated beta or Roarke
in Texas in Arizona martha mcsalley
defeated Kyrsten Sinema
florida of course not a border state but
certainly heavily impacted by
immigration Democrats lost big there too
with Andrew Gilliam losing and with Bill
Nelson seemingly losing so this stuff's
works and they're gonna continue with it
let me send a message to Democrats in
the house who are going to be sworn in
and take control of that legislative
body the immigrant Caravan
fear-mongering was a political ploy this
means therefore that when Donald Trump
sent troops to the border to protect us
from the invasion that doesn't exist
that was also a political ploy and using
the troops for political ploys should
not be tolerated people need to be held
accountable and I guess you can add that
to the list of like 60 things that
should be investigated by House
Democrats once they are sworn in in
January of 2019 send me your thoughts if
you think I'm missing something about
the disappearance of dangerous invasive
immigrant Caravan stories hours after
the election I'm on Twitter at D Pakman
the show is on twitter at david pakman
show and we've got a good program for
you today great we'll see by the end but
good definitely one of today's sponsors
is Skillshare which is an incredible
online learning community offering over
10,000 high-quality online courses on a
huge variety of topics the first 500
people who click the link under this
video will get two entire months of
totally free access to every single
class offered by Skillshare you'll have
free access to courses on music art
photography business computer
programming cooking meditation and
everything in between I think you'll
have no problem finding courses that are
perfect for you I just took a really
fascinating class on watercolor painting
which I am not yet at the level of
trying to perfect but more the level of
trying to learn even just a little bit
about our show is giving you two entire
months of totally free access to every
course offered by Skillshare risk free
if you click the link under this video
you'll have two whole months to take
classes on anything you're passionate
about classes taught by real people who
share your passion and after that you
can keep getting access to the entire
site for less than 10 bucks a month
just click the link under this video to
redeem your to three months of skill
share
hurry because it's only available to the
first 500 people who sign up